when I think about you I immediately go
the guy went to Harvard he wrote for the
Harvard Lampoon why does the
what is that you oh my God
December one most difficult college to
get into in the world there's a there's
a plus and a minus to having people know
you went to Harvard and one of the
minuses especially if you get into
comedy
is that the immediate assumption is a
little bit like if an audience knows you
went to Harvard there might be a little
oh this [ __ ] guy thinks he's better
than me huh you know this guy thinks
he's better than me and um well let's
see how funny he is and I remember him
once in the early days of our late night
show when everything was going wrong
we didn't know that you needed a warm-up
that you needed someone to warm up the
audience we I mean we said who does the
warm-up it was like the almost the first
show and they said usually it's the
announcer but we had hired an announcer
lovely guy Joel Goddard with a great
voice but he was not a comedian at all
so we just turned him loose and we were
so busy putting the show together we
weren't paying attention to how he was
warming up the crowd and I would get out
there and the crowds were the crowds
were rough the crowds were not good and
and you know I'm thinking okay this is
probably on me because everyone hates me
right now and I'm the guy that just
replaced Letterman and I'm in over my
you know everyone whatever I'm a joke
and so I maybe that's it but something
was off so one day I just had to be
putting on my tie getting ready to do
the show and Joel's out there warming up
the crowd and I go and listen and he's
saying now let me tell you something
about Conan Conan went to Harvard where
he majored in history and literature of
America he wrote a thesis on Flannery
O'Connor and William Faulkner called
literary Progeria in the world oh my God
are you kidding no and then he was like
here he is a man who's better than all
of you
here he is a man who's never hadn't done
his life well you graduate Harvard
everyone expects you to be the greatest
at everything these schools are
fantastic and they're wonderful and I
was very proud that I was accepted I had
a wonderful time there I it got me into
comedy uh I met so many brilliant people
it was lovely it's not Hogwarts there's
no such thing as Hogwarts and I think
there's this myth that uh you're gonna
go to this place and they're going to
something's going to happen a magical
thing is going to happen and it's not
true of any of those schools it's what
you bring to it it's what you do with it
and I have worked in comedy now since
1985 professionally
I would honestly tell you that
the
most brilliant people I've worked with
I don't know where they went to college
some of them didn't go to college one of
the greatest comedy writers I've ever
worked with went straight into the
military out of high school who was that
Tommy blacha
Tommy blotch is an amazing comedy writer
and one of the most original comedy
Minds I've ever met what is it you loved
about him like would you sit in a room
with him and all of a sudden talk about
anything you talk about anything I mean
he's a fascinating guy who here okay
here's something I loved about me left
our show now some people leave the show
to go work on like let's go work on an
11 30 show I'll go work for Letterman or
it didn't happen much but every now or
they've got some amazing opportunity to
run a sitcom out in La he left our show
to go work for the World Wrestling
Federation and one of my proudest
moments is one of my proudest moments in
in comedy is I used to
screw around with the writers a lot and
I would put on the attitude of this I'd
kind of like this over Larger than Life
blow I'd come into the room and I'd be
like quiet down you idiots you know and
I would go on these long Rants and I
used to one of my put-downs that I came
up with that was so stupid but I liked
it was I told uh if a writer was going
on or said something I didn't like I'd
say why don't you go have a nice tall
glass of shut up juice all right and do
yourself a favor and it was such a
stupid put down but Tommy liked it and
then Tommy said uh watch the match this
weekend and it was The Rock
well The Rock Says this you should be
concerned with fixing yourself a nice
tall glass a shut up juice
and the crowd went crazy ah crowd went
crazy then the next week Tommy said
check this out so I turn in that match
people are holding up signs that say
drink some shut up juice and Tommy was
like apologizing you know I know I I
borrowed a premium what are you talking
about Dwayne The Rock Johnson just said
it you know Vince McMahon gave you a
high five I was in heaven
foreign